I as a rule have one gift that I will  sort of like not pat myself on the back  but I fully conscious of I know how to  get along with people I'm a fairly  amenable cat and I enjoy people  my mother-in-law she's one of those few  people in life and I cannot tell you why  I except for her desire to be right  about me which is tough and it's one of  like the tougher things that we deal  with throughout our Union together now  fast-forward to now right so the good  news is we're very much aligned in terms  of how to deal with my mother and I  think that becoming a mother solidified  the fact that I'm a wife first because  in my mind  whatever happens these kids need their  dad and they need their dad and their  mom to be together and if that doesn't  happen it's not going to be because  their mom was like but my mama said  like that's it doesn't like there are a  lot of reasons that are much better than  but my mom is like how do I go look  [Music]  [Applause]